this I'm gonna be completely honest with
you and I'm about to cry I really am all
right I've had the best career when I
started this podcast everything happened
pretty much around this podcast
do you guys know that this is where my
fear sets in to it's like well while
everything sort of snow balled every
little thing that we've done into this
pod in this podcast has snowballed into
little projects for you into bigger
projects for you right but this is where
it gets a little bit icky and this is
where George and I have actually been
talking a lot in the last week we're
know you're out it's we use them in this
day and age I feel like everyone's
trying to drag innocent people through
the mud yeah and I don't think that even
I don't think there's much free speech
as we think there is and so when what
makes me nervous about it all of this is
that you know you now have let's say
like a network job and anyone
essentially can get can't a pull
anything out of context of what you've
said in this podcast because it okay
guys just say this right now okay this
podcast is out in the world it's already
out there right so if they're not gonna
vet me before signing you know giving me
a contraband but we're not mainstreaming
I don't know but still doesn't matter
it's not like as if it's not I don't you
know the other day I go you know I was
on a radio show and they had a room
wined because I said I suck dick and you
know when I was a kid yeah there's a
radio show you can't say that I'm sorry
you know I mean I just say it yeah so
I'm not gonna edit no it's not it's not
even about that what I'm saying is let's
say even if you listen to the whole
podcast really it's it's you can tell
everything is set in jest right but for
what they did to PewDiePie say for
instance he's a YouTube star with like
50 million followers yeah and he's the
top YouTube star in the world 52
probably 53 million subscribers now
if you if you took every one of those
and they voted for president he would be
for the President of the United States
so [ __ ] gross he's actually I
actually love this guy he's interesting
uh do his podcast [ __ ] so what
happened is a The Wall Street Journal
did a hit piece on him yeah basically
taking three or four videos out of
context where he like dressed up in Nazi
garb to make fun of like Nazi putting in
like some Heroes thing where you could
like flag videos for being bad he was
saying this is basically fascism so he
was making fun of YouTube once then once
he like did a video where he was like
saying that the media will take anything
out of context and he dressed up and
watch the Hitler speech oh yeah they
took that and a few other videos made
out of context did a hit piece on him he
got dropped by maker studios my Disney
yeah okay a week before maker kind of
imploded yeah but complete hit peace I
think for me it's the end of mainstream
like journalism because it's so obvious
if you look at the facts that it was a
hit piece to discredit him because the
Wall Street Journal and everybody
they're losing money but the problem
with that is for reasonable people are
you know well I mean we'll we'll look
into it and be like well this was not
he's not an anti-semite but the majority
of clickbait ders oh they're gonna eat
that [ __ ] up because they just love to
recreationally be outraged so they're
going to jump on that [ __ ] bandwagon
oh just before this I was on a tinder
date and like extensive they're lying on
it was going great and then I was like
sucking Bryce's dick it's a natural
segue if you'd listened you okay guys um
how or Fricker's so what happened
stardate no it was going great for 40
minutes but I mentioned like yeah I'd
like you know like I love YouTube like
watching just the PewDiePie like the the
YouTube drama is what you say on a first
date George it progressive like what do
you like why do you what do you want to
use you again
okay okay okay what do you want why do
you watch you
but I'm like I I don't watch it that
much I just stay up on the drama like
things like when PewDiePie gets in
trouble and she's like oh you mean that
anti-semite yeah that you pull your dick
out suck this perfect example
look another good I'll tell you why it's
not a perfect example okay I already
know people out there that don't like me
I can I could I know them okay there's
comics that don't like me
alright and what I'm saying is is that
he didn't lose anything what he lose
maker he's no way he he gained his
freedom that's what I like the free
person now and kids no longer believe
and like the media like they'll they
know that things are taken out of
context like so what do you see you guys
you guys are afraid that like something
like you know me I'm gonna get a job
like this and then one day somebody's
gonna go what somebody's gonna make a
montage of some [ __ ] that we said in
because they're not fans of ours they
don't listen well what are some of the
things that I've said that you can you
recall and then just say I wanna do it
now jungle Asians that is not fair why
that's a fact
it's a she doesn't live in the jungle
yeah that's a bad way I can't get in
trouble for that you call us mud people
like what else do you have a mud person
too but we're in the snow mud tell me
another thing that black people are oil
oh babe okay look Freddie Mercury story
I didn't somebody told me that story and
then the other thing I didn't do that if
I was the one that lost fry man [ __ ] the
little boy in the butthole and then as I
pulled my dick out hit butthole came out
with my penis I mean I told the [ __ ]
madam can I get another one that I broke
this one right that's by then of course
I don't deserve anything yeah but I'm
just telling you a story of what I heard
yeah yeah the grapevine right um so I've
never said anything not neither did
PewDiePie but he dressed up as Hitler
though that's a bad but it wasn't if you
actually in the context thing if you if
you don't believe in what he did then
satire
that's the thing you cannot take
something don't worry don't worry you
don't think I for instance like okay I
know that you know I'm one of them I but
I don't like Milo
yeah innopolis is that how you say his
last alright guy right yeah yeah
obviously like this guy is hateful
obviously like all all the adjectives
apply to him I don't particularly like
him
but I do I think that he ought to not be
allowed to speak in at college no I
think that was BS to [ __ ] he said
something about you raping or having to
have sex with underage kids it was
molested as a four doesn't matter you
don't and he didn't say it was okay he
just said look the reality is that 14
year olds do get with older people in
some countries and guess what he said he
said that he should there's really
should not be illegal look my point they
say that's just the last thing that
happened to him what I'm talking about
is more than that I'm not I'm not
defending everyone no in the song the
Filipino song like you know I dislike
him deeply our local if he had okay put
that in the montage [ __ ]
but you know people always cry about
like how dare people give him a platform
like when he was on Bill Maher how dare
people give him a platform to like spew
out this hate and stuff and it's like
look that exists everywhere you go if
you can't live your life knowing that
that exists or hearing it and you can't
possibly move on with your life I mean
there's something wrong we don't have
free speech it should we don't yeah and
that's my biggest fear about my
listeners all know that I'm dumb and did
that I don't when I say things I don't
mean it ever because I have no brain and
I have at my brain is mush and so they
know that and I don't feel like if I
look back I haven't really said anything
that was bad yeah I said you talked
about even people legitimate that's just
a hypothetical fun theory you know I
mean but cannibal I don't I don't know
if there's anything out there that can
blackmail me and if then and if they do
and some network goes you're fired
because of something you said five years
ago then that's that I know what is that
gonna do
I'm not gonna stop mmm I'm gonna stop
doing comedy I'm not gonna stop doing my
podcast just because you know you know a
corporate entity doesn't want to do
business with me that's fine
I mean I want to make money but you know
I'm not you want your free I also don't
want to play it that safe it's like you
and me look at someone like I mean don't
get me wrong he wants this Ken right but
you know you you want to show like dr.
ken and that's what he wants to do he
wants to do a family show he's a family
man he's got kids but that doesn't
necessarily mean I want ever to do that
I don't ever want to do that you know so
it's like that's his thing right but I'm
not gonna do that and there are people
that think that I'm a vile disgusting
person but most people believe that I'm
a conduit for pure love okay and then I
am Alive don't do that because you're
being sarcastic now I'm singing the song
all right you Patrignano
[Music]